let's say that we know that the
circumference circumference of a circle
is 49 pi based on that let's see if we
can figure out what the radius of that
same circle is going to be and I
encourage you and I'll write equals here
and I encourage you to pause the video
and see if you can figure it out on your
own so let's just draw the circle to
help visualize it so I'm going to do a
hand-drawn circle clearly not a perfect
circle right over here and we know that
if it's radiuses of length R that the
circumference the circumference is going
to be 2 pi times R so I could write the
circumference is equal to 2 pi times R
in fact the number pi the number pi the
standard definition for it is just the
ratio between the circumference and the
diameter of a circle now why is that
well let's just if the diameter here the
diameter here is 2r all right we have R
and then I have another R we see that
the circumference is pi times 2r or we
can say that the ratio between the
circumference and the diameter the ratio
between the circumference and the
diameter which is the ratio between C
and 2r well that's just going to be
that's just going to be pi well anyway
this was I've gone on longer than I need
to just to solve this problem so we can
go to this original formula here saying
that circumference is 2 pi times R and
we can just substitute in 49 pi for the
circumference
so we could say 49 pi is going to be
equal to 2 pi times the radius 2 pi
times the radius now let's see we can
divide both sides by 2 pi to solve for R
so dividing both sides by 2 pi on the
right hand side the 2 PI's cancel out on
the left hand side pi divided by pi
cancels out 49 divided by 2 is 24 0.5 so
if the circumference is 49 pi whatever
units then the radius is going to be 24
0.5
those units let's do one more of these
let's say that we have a circle whose
circumference I'll just say C is equal
to 1600 pi my question is what is the
diameter the diameter of the circle is
equal to what well just as we said that
the circumference could be written as 2
pi R or as pi times 2 R 2 R is just the
diameter so we could say that the
circumference is equal to PI times the
diameter and once again that comes out
of that that traditional definition of
pi is the ratio between the
circumference of the diameter you could
say that the ratio between the
circumference of the diameter is equal
to pi it's you know circles are this
very fundamental thing in the universe
and you take the ratio of the
circumference in the diameter you get
this magical and mystical number that we
see that keeps popping up in mathematics
but anyway back to the problem if we say
the circumference is 1,600 pi 1,600 pi
and this is equal to pi times the
diameter well we can just divide both
sides by PI divide both sides by PI to
get the diameter which is going to be
1600 so circumference is 1600 PI units
whatever units those are may be meters
then the diameter is just going to be
1,600 of those units or in this case may
be meters and we're all done